the issue is this  we have two branches of a decision tree  we have two branches we can go down one  branch we can go down  the other branch and they lead to very  different worlds okay  the world you're talking about now yes  we collectively humanity  humanity could drive sars kovi  to to extinction all right now if we  drive sarsko v2 to extinction  then the amount of loss gargantuan as it  has been  is finite it will come to an end right  in the same way that it has for  sars kobe 1. to support us like this  video  subscribe to the channel and consider  writing a comment and because 1984 has  captured 2021 click the link in the  description to see the full clip  on odyssey  you